Is there a blood test that tells or indicates cancer, grow it again, if so, what kind of test?
No, there isn't a blood test that specifically tells cancer is growing.
There are some things that give us clues, so you can do tuber suppressor tests or tuber marker tests.
And you can see in the blog, if you look at the blog, where do you look at the blog?
Right there, just look at the eye, click on that little eye glass and type in tuber suppressor tests.
And you'll get a list of tuber marker tests, you'll get a list of tuber marker tests that could be beneficial for your cancer.
If that doesn't totally indicate that your cancer is growing.
If your PSA, let's say for a male with prostate cancer, goes from 7 to 11, that doesn't mean it's growing.
It can, you have to look at it against, remember, not one test is perfect.
So you've got to look at that test and measure it with CT scan or MRI or ultrasound, and look at what you're willing to go through for to find that data.
So you'll also look at it and compare with subjective tests as well.